the fisa biontech vaccine has been
approved for use in the uk we've got
many millions have ordered
george utas didn't seem to be entirely
clear on exactly how many
it can be arriving here and when can you
shed any light on that
so we know that the first batch
of 800 000 is making its way to the
country now
we know that um many of
the 50 hospital hubs up and down the
country have already received their
allocation and more is expected today so
we know that that that consignment is
here and we are expecting in the low
millions so
up to four million doses to be with us
by the
end of december so so that consignment
and that distribution is really well on
the way now
um and we are in real time communication
with our member hospital trust
up and down the country and they're
telling us that they are receiving it
oh really good to get some clarity there
so uh thank you now of course we know
there are huge legit logistical
challenges to
distributing this vaccine not least of
course because it needs to be stalled at
minus
70 degrees given that is it your
understanding that it's really going to
be
given in hospital settings and will care
home residents at the front of the queue
of course to get the vaccine
will they have to travel to these
hospital hubs to receive it
you're absolutely right sophie that the
vaccine
does have to be at very very low
temperatures in very specific
environment and circumstances and it is
only hospitals who really have
the infrastructure and the facilities to
be able to do that but what they are
doing
is putting in place a phenomenal
infrastructure
to make sure that those who need to
receive it can
get it so they are calling off the
records of
all over 80s in their areas to get them
to come into the hospital
to receive their vaccinations so they're
setting up separate clinics on their
hospital sites
they are working with care home
to make sure that they can get care home
residents who are able to onto their
sets to be
vaccinated and they're also working to
make sure that those
nhs staff who are at the front of the
queue can also receive the vaccination
if it's available so
it's it's a kind of three-fold approach
making sure that
care home residents and the
over-eighties who are both at the top of
the list
can get the vaccination before we're in
a situation
where we will be able to
break those consignments of 975 doses
down and actually move them and that's
that's the situation at the moment right
now they can only be administered in
hospitals
but trusts up and down the country are
working with the mhra
who is overseeing this process to see if
they can get them distributed more
closely
to care homes so that they can go into
care homes and and
sort the vaccines for those residents
you mentioned their
nhs workers because there does seem to
be a bit of confusion about this you
know we were originally told that they
would be
you know the front of the queue in the
first batch of the vaccines and but then
it felt that that changed
the british medical association says
that as a result
of nhs workers moving down the priority
list frontline workers could die of
covid as a result
do you think nhs workers should be a
priority
the the oversight of the distribution
of vaccines falls to the jv
jcvi which is the joint committee on
vaccinations and
immunizations and they decided on the
basis of a precautionary principle
about the number of doses coming into
the country
over a period of time that it was
important to focus
on those
of dying from coronavirus and that is
the over 80s
and those in care homes and that was
because
although we've got 800 000 doses coming
into the country
because we need a double dose to
vaccinate people
that's really only a distribution to 400
000 people
um so what what was needed was a way of
making sure that those who really needed
it most
would get it but what is being adopted
now
is is a blended model so it's care
home residents over 80s
care home staff and nhs staff
and we expect the number of nhs staff
receiving the vaccine to go up
as the number of doses increases coming
into the country so
this initial focus on care home
residents and staff
as well as the over 80s was really a
precautionary principle as we understand
it obviously
the nhs isn't in control of the
distribution
of of the vaccine that falls entirely to
the
the
jcvi and their recommendation
um a big part of this of course is
persuading people to take the vaccine
and dr fauci america's top infectious
disease expert
has apologized after telling sky the
uk's
vaccine approval process was less deep
than the us
how concerned are you about public
confidence in the vaccine and do you
think that could impact take-up
well we know it's very important that
there is
high take-up of the vaccine there's a
kind of three-pronged
approach that we need to get through um
the coronavirus one is the vaccine two
is effective
therapeutics and we also
need to make sure we've got really good
testing and tracing so they are the
three elements we need
vaccines is one part of that i think
it's really important that people
understand
that the authorization and approval
process has been
incredibly robust yes it has been
shorter
other vaccine approval processes but
that's because everything has been
thrown at this
all in one go rather than the more much
more
um bureaucratic frankly process that
we've seen with other vaccine approvals
where
perhaps the need has been less pressing